foreign
let's go to Lola in canoxville in
Knoxville Tennessee what's up Lola
Dr John I was so excited when y'all
selected me because I'm in such a pickle
and you are so smart so thanks for
taking my call I like pickles and I'm
not that smart so one out of two ain't
so bad so what's up
okay so I'm in a pickle done what have
you done Lola
did you really do something this is so
great oh I can't wait okay what is it
okay so my husband and I have this
amazing 15 month old boy that we adore
and my mother-in-law and father-in-law
live six houses down from us
and when I was pregnant my mother-in-law
hated her job and we needed child care
so we begged her to retire and watch
I already know I already know you're the
worst Lola the worst
and so it was gonna be this just this
great setup
um
so she agreed
um but she said I'm taking an 1800 a
month hit by retiring early at 62
instead of 67 and she said unfortunately
I'm just gonna need some money to to to
um to live and so we agreed and like
happily I agreed and we pay her 600 a
month and she relies on that income
um and so it was just like it it was
just the Stars aligned and so fast
forward the worst Lola this is like a
slow-moving train wreck that we all know
how this part of the movie ends
okay so keep you're not the worst by the
way um okay keep going
so fast forward
um yeah I've been back at work for a
year
and
um I see I guess the part that I didn't
incorporate in my equation was
um I'm not it's like I need knew I would
need child care but I didn't think about
how I would actually want to spend time
with my son
um that like that just wasn't even like
a thought and so
um now I am
um going like every break that I get I
start as late as I can I finish as early
as I can his bedtime is 8 30 and he naps
for three to three and a half hours in
the middle of the day so that I can have
more awake time with him at night like
I'm always clawing at time with him
um and I am and I'm working full-time
now I work from home and my job I love
my job I've been here for seven and a
half years and I like I I love
everything about it it gives me so much
purpose and I make I mean I make good
money too and so
um but I'm just so tired and
um and and my husband and I you know we
really want to move out to The Burbs and
have like you know like a pool and
walking trails we can't do that because
I mean I'm not gonna drive to and from
the suburbs every day and drop him off
um that's that's going to be like a
two-hour commute I'm not doing that Lola
this has nothing to do with your
mother-in-law
I just have to do it you
well I mean do you think that I'm just
being
um I think you have I think you are a
mother of a 15 year old son and you love
him very much and you had a very clear
plan of what was going to happen next
and that plan is in Ash because you
looked at those two little those two
little eyes of that sweet little boy
and everything blew up
I'm missing three hours awake time a day
with him
especially or all of your salary and
then like what do we do with my
mother-in-law I mean she needs much she
needs our income that's your husband men
tend to solve problems with spreadsheets
okay
right and especially your husband and
your mother-in-law yeah she's in a mess
like she's kind of getting hosed here
there's no there's no getting around
that
you are you are you are experiencing in
real time
the hell that is modern American
motherhood
which is you cannot win
it is a guilt Factory if you go to work
full time and make five hundred thousand
dollars
someone's not someone you you're gonna
look in the mirror and go what kind of
mother are you
and then you say you're right I'm
sacrificing all this for my kid you're
gonna quit and then you're gonna stare
at that little lump and go what have I
done who am I I'm not even contributing
I'm such a loser and there's and then
you're gonna go to Facebook or Instagram
or Pinterest to make yourself feel
better and then you're just going to
want to set yourself on fire to see if
your makeup is flammable right there's
no way out you're just in it
accurate like yes and so this has your
mother-in-law yes she's going to be a
casualty of whatever happens here but
she's not the problem
the problem is you want it all and you
want it all right now and gosh freaking
you've had it on a plan it was on my
manifest board and it's what it's going
to look like and it's not gonna happen
that way
would I be put
yes
do you know what our question's gonna be
I don't even I don't care what the
question could be I know what the answer
is going to be what's your question
I worry in this economy on putting like
all of the financial responsibility on
my husband and then now he's gonna have
to worry about his I mean what do I do
so I think you do it in a particular
order okay are you gonna quit my job
like you're telling me no no no
I'm about to ask you are you going to
quit your job
take all of the pools take all of the I
shoulds and shouldn't take all that junk
all that crap off the table
take all of the mother-in-law and is my
husband gonna have to actually take all
that off
are you gonna quit your job
well I mean like that's dependent on the
answer to those questions it's not those
questions are dependent on that answer
and here's the thing there's not a right
or wrong to it
there's a seasonal response
and you my good friend are so good at
clouding up a simple decision simple
questions with noise because that's how
you get through all hard things
so you're so good at it
like I need to have a hard conversation
with my husband but I can make a good
dinner and we can go do this and it'll
be fun we'll go to the show and then it
will just go away it doesn't ever go
away
just
um
that's why you just got to go forward
you got to do the best thing right now
and that thing by the way will change
and it might mean what do we do with my
mother-in-law though
do we like I mean I think I think the
ethical fair thing is to give her a
pretty long Runway
yeah if anybody in the world would
understand I'm a mom
and I feel like I'm watching my son's
life slip through my fingers while I'm
here typing away on design spreadsheets
or something I don't know what you do
for a living but like I I feel like I'm
missing it
um whatever it is right and by the way
it
is insanely boring
maddeningly boring
well like being a mom being a
stay-at-home oh my gosh I mean
unfathomably boring
and it's right
do you think I would be trading like
what a lot of people at my cup there's I
have a lot of moms on my team that did
come back to work and the reason they
did was because we all have similar
situations where it's just like
it's not like we have to sit in traffic
for two hours a day and we don't like
it's not like we're only seeing two
hours a day with them like I see a lot
of him I just
what are you missing
I'm missing three to four hours a day of
wake time okay
and and because I have to put him down
so late to get that wake time I feel
like I mean I'm just so tired because I
feel like I'm doing
two full-time jobs like I see six to
seven hours a day of him awake he's only
awake for like
whatever nine I mean but some of this is
very very seasonal you're talking like
six more months
what do you mean like in just a few more
months he's going to start napping way
way less and be way more all over the
place and then in a year and a half he's
going to be in a Tuesday Thursday school
and then in two more years or three more
years he's going to be in kindergarten
it goes so fast
and so
I like right now you are making a very
static long-term decision on a very
fluid situation
so I'm wondering if I could just add
what if I drop down to part-time then
you I'm not you you have spit your
entire how many people did you ask if
your husband was the right guy to marry
probably a thousand
um well yeah the first two years when we
were dating yes like every single thing
that came up I had advice from my
girlfriend yes we need to get a copy we
gotta talk let's go talk let's go get
drink I gotta talk yes you Lola I'm not
taking this from you you're gonna have
to be all grown up
John Loney
exactly I'm not gonna take your decision
because here's why you also blame
everybody when you do take their advice
and you gotta own this one
[Laughter]
like I love my job but like what I'm not
gonna have 24 hours a day with him like
what am I going to be doing during this
time and so I said can I just take like
18 months off until he becomes a toddler
because when he's a toddler it's like
more work and whatever and he like
mansplained me out of it but my
mother-in-law heard that I was
considering it and so she texted him and
said hey is Lola gonna gonna take some
time off because if so I'm just gonna
push my I'm gonna push my retirement
back I can't afford to retire without
this and so then he like mansplained me
out of it he was like but this and this
and this and this and you can see him
during your breaks and you know look at
all of this future that you can provide
and whatever and so I like when I I
didn't and also like all the
consequences of I'm in a senior level
position at work and it's like I have it
made and all of this stuff and so I knew
about it and so when you say blaming
others I mean I did tell him before she
was actually retired like hey like I
don't know if I I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to give my baby up and you
know he talks me out of it and I'm like
still feeling the same thing I was
feeling a year ago and you're right like
I just feel
kind a little bit of his time flipping
through but then also like I see so much
little like I see
um like my entire life revolves around
him because you're a working mom like I
don't get my nails done anymore I know I
know but listen listen this this is this
is it
here's what you haven't done yet
um you've probably heard me say this on
the show before and I'll say it again
when when my wife got pregnant with Hank
my my 12 year old
I literally started a clock
like okay nine to ten months and I'll
get my wife back
and what that meant was not she didn't
go anywhere and she was still awesome
we're still having fun but like in nine
or ten months like it's like the Disco
lights come back on we can just make out
in the middle of the night if we want to
we just go like hey let's just go to
Denny's it's 2 A.M I know let's just do
it like like we had this life let's just
drive to Dallas and go to a concert
let's do it like we had this life and I
kept waiting until that life could would
come back
and it wasn't until my son because I'm
in hard-headed [ __ ] it wasn't until I
was he was eight or nine or ten and I'd
almost blown up everything
that I realized oh that life is over
it doesn't exist anymore and you haven't
done that yet
so I'm just gonna be perpetually
exhausted for the next 18 years whether
I'm working congratulations welcome to
Parenthood myself listen when I told my
Dad hey Dad we're having a I'm having a
baby
he said well
you're never going to sleep again that
was the first thing he said
because he's a he's a brilliant
pragmatist so yes you're going to be
tired for the rest of days
yes you know why even if I quit my job
and I don't have to work and I just have
to hold him I'll still be tired and I
just have him all still be tied you are
smarter than the answer is yes yes and
the booth all the parents back here are
dying laughing they're all laughing yes
yes I just want to watch a TV show nope
in 2048 you can watch whatever show you
wanted
whatever show you want to
and here's what's so hey can I tell you
what's so great about this you're about
three months away from one either you or
your husband being like you wanna have
another one and be like yep
it's just refusing to have another he
said he's totally done he said under no
circumstances we're totally done okay
can I be super like I've been laughing
with you because I know this is
miserable and I also know like like
here's me being very serious
um you and your husband are not on the
same page and this is a recipe for a
mess down the road
and you are super fun and you'd be
really fun to like get beers with and
hang out I can already I can tell you
you're fun but you avoid hard
conversations with him and you cave
and there's gonna come a point when that
caving is gonna turn into a nightmare
attorney like he is so good at making
his point and it makes so much sense
um and so yeah but but you're not you
and your son's relationship is not a
spreadsheet
it's not a problem to solve
your financial situation if you quit an
incredible job might be a financial
problem to solve but that comes on the
back end of what's right right now
and you keeping your job and finding
ways I guarantee it I guarantee it
there are ways for you to rest in this
season
it's going to take a you're going to
have to back out and say what has to go
um I'm trying to figure out what that is
I know and there's you want to do
everything all at the same time you just
can't
and so I it sounds to me like you have
the greatest possible situation
which is I've got somebody that I trust
who I actually love who's not a maniac
taking care of my kid inside my house
that I can see him all the time and I'm
making a killer salary
and that's when you and your husband
need to go out and stop doing a hey
here's a feeling I have here's a concern
I have boom here's a spreadsheet answer
like you can't live like that
we do I know but here's what's gonna
happen you're gonna go on a business
conference and someone's gonna listen to
you for the first time
and nothing's gonna happen and you're
going to text or you're gonna get their
email address and say hey it was great
to talk to you and now you're off
somewhere else
that's how that happens
or your husband's gonna get not like the
person he becomes because he's trying to
make love to a spreadsheet and he's
going to begin to want to become a
different person
this is how this happens okay
ah
and you 100 know I'm right
one more okay serious question one more
my dad died of a heart attack because he
was working so much because my my
stepmom milked him for every penny that
he had and then my husband's dad died
like very similarly like
ex-wife baby mama drama child support
all of that and so like I mean would I
be putting his health at risk or like
you know like buy to eliminate I mean we
could we would be fine with if I quit or
drop down to part-time but like I just
feel guilty like especially in Peak
inflation and all that I mean
what do you think about the added
pressure on a man to like like have to
support a family I would say that my
wife made an incredible income when she
was a fancy research professor
and then when I wasn't well and we took
a 70 000 house dollar household income
pay cut 70 grand and we moved to a new
town so I could work with a smaller
group of students and get my head
screwed back on
and she worked part-time there and she
worked part-time and volunteered and was
a writer and whatever else she did
and I struggled a just because of the
math because I wanted to look at the
spreadsheet and had some financial goals
and I got tired of driving her old
Corolla around right and I was making a
great salary as the dean of students at
a law school is making a great salary as
the chief student affairs officer at
College X and Y like but it wasn't
manifesting it wasn't playing out my
life because I was the only guy right
yeah and then here's what happened I got
my wife back
I got my life back
I got my kids back
and there is no dollar amount for that
I'll drive a Corolla till the end of
time
yeah
see what I'm saying but yeah it also
took us going to counseling and learning
how to have a new kind of relationship
it also took um several years of us in
several near misses to recalibrate our
marriage because it was just super
different it was a different marriage
than the one that we had when we first
got married it was just a totally
different one
yeah
and so
that's the work ahead of you it's in in
here's the thing you're gonna quit your
job and you're going to be so frustrated
that you're broke or that you have to
drive old cars or that you can't move or
you might have to move you might have to
downsize
well he would just
this is 100 percent
this is you caught in the system that's
that's the air right there's no getting
around that
you all need to go talk to somebody
I'm just telling you and he's gonna say
why what oh you only play golf fine I'll
quit playing that's not it that's not it
it's not it
it's beneath that it's that you have a
picture of what this whole thing's
supposed to look like and it's not gonna
happen
and he has a picture of what it's going
to look like and it's not gonna happen
it's not and that is the beauty
of being married and that's the beauty
of it all like of playing forward is you
don't know how it's going to wrap up but
it's not going to be this and so you can
do one of two things you can just keep
trying to make this thing happen until
you crash this sucker into the ditch
or you can say all right that picture's
over that was a blast now we got to do
something new and in this new picture
you're gonna play less Golf and be
around more
in this new picture we're going to cut
our expenses by 25 I'm going to sell the
new car and I'm gonna buy an old car
that can get me to and from and
um
by the way you can put two or three car
seats in a Corolla nobody's gonna die
right you're gonna look ridiculous and
you're going to be like have to squish
and squeeze and lean overnight it's
frustrating but you can be just fine
okay
so why am I saying that you can cut
expenses Lola it's deciding we want this
over this
and this over this is an admission that
we can't have everything all the time
right now
it just is it just is
I don't think you should quit your job
if I'm being if I'm just in surgery I
don't think you should quit your job
because I think you love your job
I think your marriage is a mess
I think your marriage is messier than
you want to admit it and I think that is
making the ground you walk on very
unstable
because you're a year plus into this new
marriage with a kid and all of a sudden
you feel things starting to slip through
your fingers and you are a control
person
she can't love your wives and
spreadsheets all the time sometimes yes
but most of the time it's best just to
sit and listen say tell me what we're
working through
tell me what we're working through
I'm grateful for you Lola thank you so
so much for the call
um holler back at me when you decide
what to do I'm gonna hear how this one
ends